[Music]
over watches a game all about variety a
shooter for all play styles and
personalities for all skill levels and
tastes the huge amount of choice and
diverse is one of the many reasons I
adore it that and them sweet curves but
having spent many hours playing with
friends and strangers alike and hearing
people talk about their characters and
classes I wanted to ask the question
could overwatch be in danger of having
too many heroes Before we jump too far
down that rabbit hole of a question
though make sure you subscribe to
GameSpot we've got all the gameplay
reviews and weird questions about
overwatch that you'd ever want now I'm
not saying that overwatch does have too
many heroes I just think it's
interesting to examine the growing
roster and perhaps to look at some of
the problems that may arise from having
an abundance of characters and I would
really love to hear what you think
whether you're a veteran player battling
through comp a newcomer getting a feel
for the game in casual or someone just
thinking about picking up overwatch for
themselves with the release of doom
fists overwatch now has 25 heroes that's
for more than the game launched with and
the folks at Blizzard showed no signs of
slowing down character releases there
are a few games today that can boast
such a broad unique and varied cast and
while it's fantastic that any player can
fill any role or playstyle they want
such a scope is not without its
disadvantages
for all the overwatch players I know
myself included our character playtime
stats
seem to share one thing in common they
all start with one huge chunk of color
usually our main followed by a big
decline in time spent with other
characters often down to single digit
minutes but the thing that bugs me is
each one of those characters I've spent
only a handful of minutes on is a whole
lot of overwatch I'm missing out on
Farah and Roadhog dominate the peak of
my staff mountain but Winston is stuck
way down at the bottom and yet he's
currently one of the most played heroes
in competitive play while overwatch has
an abundance of character options it has
nothing on the hundred and thirteen
heroes that dota 2 currently features
which is one of the main reasons why I
just couldn't stick with that game that
and I got horrendously salty obviously
the environment down here is all soft
the ceiling soft for assault the walls
are soft and to an extent the aerosol
dota 2 has a real accessibility problem
with players having clocked over 100
hours still being considered novices I
played around 90 hours mostly across
four or five heroes and whenever I
looked at the roster I became
overwhelmed and intimidated with the
sheer amount of options available to a
lesser extent this is still the case for
overwatch and many people i've
evangelized the game to have said
something similar when they talked about
getting into overwatch although the
beauty of overwatch is its simplicity
it's an easy game to pick up find a
character understand how said character
plays and how they fit into the broader
flow of a match however with every new
character doing that becomes a little
more difficult every new hero requires a
learning process how to play them how to
counter them how to compose them as part
of a team the more hair is added the
longer the process over time this could
become a problem
in growing the community I get that
there are many factors involved with who
you roll out with the start of the game
or even who your main is for example I
play a lot of Farah because I played a
lot of soldier in Team Fortress 2 so her
rocket launching play style is very
familiar to me too more likes to play a
lot of Zarya because he like strong
ladies with pink hair and Lucy plays a
lot of Mae because she just likes to
watch people suffer but pressure from
teammates in the ever-evolving meta game
that is the current strongest hero team
composition or strategy also plays a big
part in who picks what especially in
competitive play the game has moved from
the two to two met
last year to triple tank meta and most
recently over watch his dive meta the
two to two stack gave healers and
supports more playtime triple tank
obviously saw more playtime with tankier
characters and the latest dive matter
sees more hypermobile characters like
winston tracer and Genji and i hate it
despite the introduction of new
characters the meta could be pushing
people away from exploring new
characters in favor of ones that have
been proven to win and there's the
fandom I'd be naive in thinking that new
animations comics collectors and skins
don't influence a character's pic right
the bastion movie was adorable but oh
boy those pesky robots sure came at the
woodwork that evening
while there's only so much the community
can do to help mold a character it's
fascinating to see how a character
reception in the community their play
time and their viability can shift so
drastically as the game grows and gets
rebalanced heroes change depending on
those changes whether he receives a buff
or a nerf the amount they are played in
casual and competitive circles can also
be affected usually if a player base
starts shying away from a character like
I have with Roadhog with his recent
changes it could potentially be a sign
that they're in need of buffing
similarly if a character is buffed too
hard it becomes overpowered players will
start to gravitate towards a hero
possibly being a sign that their stats
might need another look at and thus the
cycle of buffing nerf it continues until
the game eventually hits some kind of
equilibrium but with the amount of
characters overwatch has that may be a
challenge each new character is a new
set of variables to fact it into a game
that already has a mind-boggling number
of abilities health pools damage output
and defense that's to balance in Tamar's
interview with overwatch director Jeff
Caplan he said most players either main
one or two heroes he added that they had
24 heroes at the time and we have to
represent all those people to make sure
they are fun to play and play against
that nothing dominates the balance but
as it stands the stats show that that
isn't quite happening the global stats
show despite blizzards best efforts
certain characters are being played way
more than others
someone could even make the case was
slowing down character releases
altogether and instead focus on
improving the play time for the ones
that we have now it'd be nice to see a
few more sombras around but that mean
Blizzard needs to make herb more useful
to players a games constant changes and
evolutions isn't a challenge that is
unique to overwatch it's something
multiplayer PvP games must account for
in their roadmap adjusting to shifts in
gameplay and player behavior Team
Fortress 2 again with nine heroes was
still receiving balanced changes to
characters nearly ten years after its
release
dota 2 with his aforementioned 113
characters is still being balanced and
rebalance on a monthly basis over four
years after its initial release endure a
tuesd case especially it's important for
the game to be in a constant state of
balance for its eSports presence but
even then over half of its roster is
picked less than 7% of the time during
tournaments overwatch is making big
strides into the eSports arena with the
game being played at tournaments
everywhere and even supporting its own
World Cup and yet there are heroes in
the roster
pick less than 1% of time in competitive
play seemingly the variety that
overwatch has is at odds with its roster
we may have 25 heroes to choose from but
that doesn't stop many the matches just
being compositions of the same 15 again
and again as players and viewers I feel
like we might be missing out a lot of us
here at games but a massive overwatch
fans it's safe to say that there's
always at least one member of GameSpot
playing on any given day so while it's
fun to chat about heroes and pick rates
I want to ask them and you the viewers
this question do you think overwatch has
or could be in danger of having too many
heroes yeah I think that it's actually
pretty good right now I think that
they're adding the you know one every
couple months and that feels pretty
solid considering the roster that they
have and the different kind of class is
that people play I mean answer yes and
no because right now I feel like they
they have a very good balance with the
heroes that they do have it could be the
case where if they keep on adding more
and more maybe 10 years down the line
they just come to a point where they
can't they have they just struggle
balancing them then yeah they might have
too many by then I think as of right now
it feels good it feels comfortable with
what they have I think of the minute it
doesn't have too many characters I think
25 is it good and my own I mean the
whole point of overwatch is that people
you can change characters and you can
counter whatever the enemy team is
picking so I think 25 is a great cool to
have especially with six players on
either side compared to a lot of other
gains that our hero based has a lot of
heroes I think if you look at something
like dota or League of Legends those
rosters of characters are huge so right
now it's it doesn't seem to have a lot
of characters at all actually I feel
like maybe they should put the press the
pause button for a little while and let
the characters kind of just be out there
and that people figure more characters
out and maybe spend some time kind of
stabilizing the balance a bit so would
be good to see them stop putting out new
characters and instead tried to create
new matters around the ones that they
already have in the game so far the four
new characters that they've introduced
have all been they've all been really
good you know they've been solid
characters well balanced characters so I
feel like until they get to a dud where
you know the character doesn't land
quite as well or it's not really
balanced and maybe they can you know
take a step back and reevaluate the
heroes that they do have
I think that win overwatch eventually
hits the 30 or 40 hero amount I think
it's still gonna play roughly the same
wizard doesn't release characters
without knowing that they still have to
have overall balance within the game and
so I think the game will ultimately
still play very similarly you'll just
have to learn some new tricks and things
like that oh man overwatch with 40
characters I think it'd be real messy
it's only a matter of time before we get
another Symetra or again G and Lord
knows we don't need more of them but in
a minute 25 is fine thanks road hog
today's please so we are about as
divided on whether or not the game has
too many characters as the overwatch and
Talon organizations are on the ideas of
heroism but really isn't the fact that
so many of us are still so passionate
about this game a year down the line a
testament to what overwatch has achieved
I think we all just hope that Blizzard
can continue to build in this foundation
and trust that it will do so without
compromising the fun that drew us into
the game has kept us playing it but I
want to know what you guys think let us
know in the comments section your
thoughts on the cast of overwatch and
what you'd like to see for overwatch a
year down the line in an upcoming video
I'm going to get the overwatch fanatics
here a game spot to play their leagues
played hero in an attempt to mix things
up and maybe see if I can get them to
abandon their manes in favor of someone
new so make sure you hit that subscribe
button so you don't miss it again thank
you so much for watching and I will see
you next time
[Music]
obviously the environment down here is
all saw the the ceiling saw before
assault the walls are soft and to an
extent the air is so and you breathe
that in and you can constantly taste the
soft